not for me hey man hey hey
tupac was one of the biggest thugs i
know and he
good point all always let me tell you
something
when i get in the ring
everybody knows that my hands aren't
regular hands and when i plant my hands
on you you best believe that they gonna
grow and they gonna grow in the right
direction i'm talking about the
direction of taking your air and taking
it out your body and making you breathe
from your butt and that's not a fart
that's called a poop i'm known for
squeezing poops out of people's butts is
that not right billy big bob i'm a poop
squeezer son of a so you ask yourself
will you step in a ring with me if you
got gas and if you do then that means
i'ma squeeze it out yours
yeah
get the out of the way
[Applause]
[Laughter]
the joke's not supposed to go on that
long
let's see this is what i gotta deal with
on jumanji
okay you ready you guys ready
this is the last award this is an
exciting award look at kevin hart look
at kevin hart
thank you jesus
i just want to say it because every time
you say it people go crazy thank you
jesus
uplifting the community thank you jesus
is what the hoodie he is real
he is real
oh wow
gas
petrol station
petrol pump what
petrol pump gas
petrol that's a gas pump where's their
nitrogen down you know what you guys
like to do well waste breath
petrol pump yeah petrol petrol pump yeah
petrol pump i gotta go stop at the
petrol pump okay i need gas right here
slow down okay slow down hey man stop
cutting us off okay no man you cutting
us off jack
this penny has your name on it man
y'all's about to throw this penny she's
about to throw a penny at you you see
diana driving she's a student driving
man
get your [ __ ] together
one is a community activist for children
i was gonna go to the strip club but i'm
not gonna go because jesus is here
[Applause]
driving a car without power windows is a
big mistake i can't do this all day and
do you know how to stick with this lip
then you go
what is the loudest animal on earth
sperm whale
b hyena or c
cicada it's this is just a question yes
and you answer one of those is the
is the sperm well is he is he releasing
like is he
haha [ __ ] you thought i was juggling we
out here doing promo cue tell me doing
promo promo [ __ ] promo [ __ ] tell you
promo [ __ ] promo [ __ ] tell them to get
cute you know what we doing but you tell
em it's better when you tell me times i
gotta find promo b we do a movie
kevin hart to me mean you do a movie
can we do a comedy together
i'm doing all this to get with you man
turn up man turn it off baby
all i got to say to you is
1549 receptions okay 208 touchdowns
895 yards
what what 26 catches uh 37
37 what those are drops no okay 26
catches i had 13 nope that wasn't that
wasn't me that was that was terrance i
had five touchdowns 26 catches and i had
i think i had like two right but listen
to yourself look five compared to 208
touchdowns obviously you played more
games oh my god i mean come on you don't
have to be a rocket scientist figure
that out all right i had five touchdowns
in one game okay and who was it against
atlanta falcons bingo shoot central
television
i'm shooting my videos
[ __ ] your fans that's right it's gonna
be awesome i'm starting off with
something very cute and cuddly this is
gisele
come on
come on
[Music]
[Music]
what are you doing i'm about to thank
jesus again
i just want to say it all the time
kurt look at me kurt
i mean you want to just hold on a second
there we go i just want to make sure
that you don't fall back and hit your
soft spot man if you don't get your hand
off my [ __ ] head i hear a man
of short stature that does not mean i'm
a baby
hey huh huh huh
how many kids on that
hey just tell me how many keys
let me see it man we got
you know what i'm saying just little
bitty baby
here's the number one rule in hollywood
don't work with no [ __ ] animals don't
work with no [ __ ] kids i agree i did
are we there yet and they're 10 times
more professional than this one you got
you know what you've got another thing
coming
i don't know if we could do that go
what
what
what do you say
[Laughter]
don't even i don't like
what i will be the first to pee on
dwayne the rock johnson star on the
hollywood walk of fame
you say dwayne johnson can tie his balls
in and not older guys have long balls
i've actually executed on two of those
things already
uh on his star i took a [ __ ] on his star
on hollywood
sorry about this sir
crosswalk right now sir here's a good
thing about me first and foremost i'm a
christian and
what i learned is that
jesus once walked on water
i don't know where i'm going with this
guys
[Music]
[Music]
yo the reason why i go with onesies
because i'm small so i like to be in one
thing i don't like taking things off in
pieces give me one piece my kids feel
the same way but we zipped ourselves all
the way up in that and we played a
little game called figure it out uh
that that game ended fast because my son
fell down the steps i said
i said don't go that way he said i gotta
figure it out i said all right
of tonight's nominees and to present the
best community leader winner with the
keys of the 2018 that's me that's me
right there that's me i'm reading it
watch out
watch out everybody move this is my part
no no no y'all gotta step back
everybody step back
[Laughter]
you see me do kurt franklin with one leg
do you ever consider collaborating
together oh yeah
what
oh yeah rapping and joking what is your
dream we rapping
no collaborations unless we collaborate
at the end of the day it makes you
contemplate oh my god what am i thinking
i'm thinking but i'm wrong come along
with me on this ride alone oh stop me
long don't ride
long don't rhyme with long hater hit fun
police
great question who's the best actor of
all time um well you know what when you
you go best actor yes of all time right
it's a great question this is a
fantastic fantastic question of all time
you got to go with somebody that i don't
know has uh
blocks off his revenue charisma charming
uh a guy who has multiple careers that
you can that you can choose from you
know i mean success in one area and then
immediately gain success in another yeah
um god how many people have done that
right and and somebody that fans follow
love enjoy
right
um
goodness gracious stature big you know
big heart uh giving um
brother iced tea
gotta go with iced tea
yep that's my answer ice tea
[Laughter]
because you do swear a lot on stage i i
do i get away with it it's like my voice
is small enough to where it's not
offensive yeah well
i've used that excuse as well it doesn't
always work because you're tall you
can't do the same thing that's what it
is watch this come on man stop being a
[ __ ] say that small come on don't be a
[ __ ] yeah now if i say like you don't
be a [ __ ] whoa hey buddy
and the winner for best community leader
is
jesus
sorry i'm sorry
i'm sorry
i'm sorry
i got the spirit i'm sorry